diddy you know it's been a minute since
he dropped new music but guess what
y'all it's coming but first diddy is
hosting an executive producing this
sunday's billboard music awards
bigger than the city lights down in
times square
you know ain't no party like a diddy
party none tell me that you're killing
me still sonic's performing megan the
stallion ed sheeran morgan wildin i'm
gonna need some whiskey glasses we gonna
have a battle
what yeah
we got some of the greatest performers
in the world
i'm raiding the performances
cause we bringing makes them and making
the band diddy in there the strong will
survive that we shall perish let's go
diddy promises a night of surprises when
the billboard music awards air sunday on
nbc live from vegas mary j blige is
being honored with the icon award that's
my sister
that's the first artist that believed in
me and so everything to come full circle
this is truly truly a full circle moment
yeah you want to talk full circle e.t
first met a 26-year-old puffy at the
awards show in 1995. he had just started
his first record label do you remember
your first billboard award you were with
it's a great thing to be recognized with
young and you know young and black and
we're just doing it and we i'm proud of
him and i'm proud of the company
it's a beautiful thing i thank god for
it yo i'm so blessed what do you
remember about that night that's the
first award we had ever got so that was
such an important night we was coming
from nothing
more than 25 years later the mogul is
worth an estimated 900 million dollars
thanks to his clothing line music
royalties and several other lucrative
partnerships but now he's back in the
studio and getting ready to drop his
first album in seven years i am
returning yes
i am returning i want to bring back real
r b so i decided to start my own label
love records what would you tell the
dude who showed up on the howard
university campus if you could go back
right now and just whisper in his ear
yeah i would be whispering what i was
whispering in his head in
is that you're going to do it yeah
you're going to do it but i will go back
and say yo we did it
just want to let you know
we did it
[Music]
i don't think we give diddy his flowers
enough what do you mean it's love we
spread love he does it all he does it
all
you